we're gonna begin with this today
Republican congressman Chris Collins
says he will fight federal charges of
insider trading and run for re-election
The New Yorker who's a key ally of
President Trump is charged with
conspiracy securities and wire fraud and
making false statements to the FBI video
uncovered by CBS News appears to show
Collins on his phone at the moment
prosecutors say he gave inside
information to his son Tony Duke Opel is
at the Manhattan federal courthouse
where Collins appeared yesterday Tony
good morning good morning Collins his
son and the father of his son's fiance
face 13 charges altogether they pled not
guilty to all of them in a courthouse
here behind me yesterday and they're now
free on a $500,000 bail bond that may
sound like a lot but investigators say
their combined trades save them more
than seven hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in what would have been losses
the charges that have been levied
against me are meritless hours after
federal prosecutors arrested Republican
Chris Collins on accusations of insider
trading the New York representative said
he looked forward to being fully
vindicated and exonerated throughout my
tenure in Congress I have followed all
rules and all ethical guidelines
according to the indictment Collins sat
on the board and was the top shareholder
of innate immunotherapy Unix an
Australian biotechnology company Collins
was at the White House picnic last
summer when the FBI says he got an email
from an aide CEO with quote bad news one
of the company's most important products
and intended treatment for multiple
sclerosis was a clinical failure Wow
Collins wrote back according to the
indictment how are these results even
possible footage uncovered by CBS News
appears to show what allegedly happened
next
Collins on the phone with his son
Cameron illegally sharing news of the
disastrous drug trial
the FBI says Cameron began dumping his
shares of the company and past the tip
to his fiancee and her father when news
of the drug failure broke five days
later in eight shares dropped 92% Donald
Trump is a movement Collins was the
first congressman to endorse then
candidate Trump
on Wednesday he became the first
congressman to be charged with a crime
since Trump's presidency
congressman Collins who by virtue of his
office helps to write the laws of our
nation acted as if the law didn't apply
to him there was a lot of suspicious
stock trading activity
Craig Holman is with the advocacy group
Public Citizen which flagged Collins
alleged misconduct early last year
suddenly I suspect many members of
Congress are going to start reevaluating
whether they want to continue playing in
the stock market
now Collins faces as much as a hundred
and fifty years behind bars if convicted
on all those counts his attorney is
quick to point out that Collins is not
accused of trading any stock himself
just passing along that information and
he says his client looks forward to
mounting a vigorous defense and
rebutting all those charges now we
should point something out this may
surprise people it is legal for a
sitting member of Congress to serve on a
corporate board as long as he or she is
not being paid directly flat that's a
good point Tony to Coppa for us thank
you Tony